hi I'm Guillermo El Toro and I'm Phil
wolfhard and this is our wired
autocomplete interview exactly
[Music]
I normally use a dog.go is that because
it's the most secure I like the cartoon
yes yeah yeah
[Music]
all right what is
fan wall first first movie well the
first movie I ever watched was the first
Sam Remy Spiderman really yeah because
it looked at Young yeah I know yeah yeah
yes that was the first one we ever saw
and the first movie I was ever in I
guess was was it oh yeah yeah what
skateboard dogs Finn Wolford have when I
was younger I was much more into
skateboarding I remember the first one I
ever had was
flip it's called flip I favored Gurney
oh yeah yeah you love Transportation
yeah if there was any wheel yeah wheel
of Transportation it would be the granny
first yeah what is film Wolf's heart
Hogwarts house did you ever take the
test no what is that it's like in Harry
Potter The House of different houses in
Harry Potter anyways oh Hogwarts yeah
why I read hogwash what is your hug I
think it's I think I did take the online
test which was I think I was Hufflepuff
I don't really remember I think it's
just not like niceness or kindness or
something what music does being
Boulevard listen to out there you go in
this past year it's been because of that
Beatles documentary that Peter Jackson
put out it's mostly been Beetle stuff
fantastic yes bye
these are the hard-hitting questions
what is going to Toro known for oh well
now I'm a doctor yeah yeah the
University made me a doctor so I'm known
for Magical cures for anything from
incontinence to Dry Leprosy but other
than that making movies on monsters
what influences
mostly breakfast and books and art I've
been schooling myself on Fine Arts since
I was a really young guy and I've been
schooling myself on breakfast from
beginning to now this is what does Gear
with a tour smell like
what do you like to do besides eat
breakfast I really the thing I adore is
on Sundays I get together with other
directors and we paint model kits I
heard when I was a kid that if you went
to Hollywood and we're a director you
were surrounded by models so I have a
monster model an airplane model we just
paint them on Sunday listen to movie
music is super nerdy
you feel you paint now
Alejandro comes drops by to have coffee
when he doesn't paint it he doesn't
paint no no what is Guillermo del Toro
first movie that I saw it was Wuthering
Heights I remember the storm and I was
super scared and then I went to sleep
and the second one was Pinocchio with my
mom and the first movie I made was a
Chronos which looks like the first movie
it feels like a first movie well I mean
it's a Criterion so yeah they think it's
good all right here we go is Finn
wolfhard a singer I sing okay I sing
fine sing something what do you want me
to sing
see you're good at it is film wolfhard
directing a movie I'm directing a film
yeah Sasha comedy and I'm really excited
about it advice do you have for a young
director patience and serenity and show
the movie to your friends before your
enemies see it It's Finn wolfhard in The
Addams Family I was in the first
animated film and played Pugsley that
was pretty amazing have you seen the new
Wednesday I haven't seen it yet no no I
saw the dance with the cramps right
right yeah I do love timber fantastic is
film wolfhard coming back to stranger
things I hope so I hope they haven't
fired me yet next year we go back for
the final season
that's it I don't know I think I'm just
gonna miss the camaraderie I guess
between people when you go back and work
with the same crew and people every day
it's kind of like graduating from
college or something or I would imagine
I don't know I'm a child actor so yeah
catering catering mostly that's probably
the best part I would say is Finn
wolfhardt
biling no I I wish I was I do truly want
to learn Spanish that's the next
language well it's awesome
when did Pierre Del Toro come to America
I'm three years old I went to Disneyland
for the first time and my head exploded
and my father used to bring us almost
every year and it was the most fun in
the world did you go to Galaxy's Edge
yet no you haven't been oh yeah no no
yes I did yeah I was I was screaming
like a child yeah
look at that oh yeah
how did Gyro Del Toro become a director
I started directing I always say when
people tell me we want to be directors
to say you should already be I mean you
can direct without a camera you can
direct with an iPhone you're gonna
direct with anything now if you start
telling little stories about breakfast
or other things I mean just simple
stories somebody going from one room to
the next tell that story and you're
directing how many movies has Guero Del
Toro exactly 12 so far 12 so far are
there any movies that you look back on
when you want to redo yeah well to a
point I mean I think Chronos and mimic I
would have loved to know more than I did
but after that I'm pretty much I'm happy
how many Oscars does gear without Toro
have yeah too I like it but you know I
can put things in the middle you know
and they don't fall off the shelf let's
throw it there you go
oh sorry let's see this one does it feel
more hurt like anime anime I do like
anime my brother is a voice actor and
he's always loved anime I'm not as big
of a nut as he is but I really love and
respect Anime favorite anime death note
I think death is brilliant I still have
to watch have you seen chainsaw man yet
no this must be unbelievable yeah
play video games yeah I do I used to
when I was more when I was a lot younger
like I grew up on all the like PS1 PS2
games like the Jack and Daxter series
and nowadays if I have any time I
usually just kind of like to turn my
brain off and play like Call of Duty or
something does Finn wolfhard
like that I do I have a cat she's
actually my wallpaper zoom on this one
there she is
poppy her name is Poppy why why did Ben
Wolford almost quit acting because it
had a director before any musketti and I
was cast in that version of it I was a
week to shooting I was so excited and
then it was canceled and I was so
discouraged and I was like if this is
gonna keep happening there's no way like
in my head I was like there's no way I
mean it does it's like a loss
Guillermo del Toro Bleak House oh yeah
well it's three big houses it's two
houses and one apartment where I keep my
collection it's shameful I basically
live with life-size silicone figures of
horror monsters and I talked to them
every morning I come in and there's a
one and I say hey how are you John is
John Merrick from The Elephant Man it's
really sad but you know what it's a sad
I perspired all my life okay camera Toro
favorite movies that's hard and easy I
mean today right now for this exercise
Frankenstein Bridal Frankenstein the
World Warrior greed vertigo probably
yeah
little Toro hell boy yeah you know I did
two of them I liked them I kept wrong
Brahman uh decently employed you know
the gun that is yeah the Samaritan how
long did that take to figure out it took
a while because it was very heavy and
Ron has very weak arms we needed to put
a wire on the tip of the gun oh so that
he wouldn't shake right that's hilarious
so you would be pulling him up like a
fishing like you caught fish I'm sorry
Ron yeah camera Toro Museum same thing
as lake house and I will try to do it in
the future to buy a house and house the
main pieces of the collection and open
it to the public for free give a loturo
drawings I'm a self-taught uh draft man
and I draw decently enough to put them
on my Diaries one of my desires is in
the very immediate future go back and
actually learn formal painting do you
storyboard your movies every single
story but yeah even Pinocchio no we
Pinocchio especially I have the the
story words and then I Vibe with the
actors and I can change anything on a
second that's yeah that's amazing throw
it bye all right film wolfhard
Pinocchio yes I'm in Guillermo's
Pinocchio I play Candlewick and it was
one of the great experiences you did
great good beautiful Workman
deer-inducing Beauty oh thank you man
does from overwear away for stranger
things is real this is all real all
right you know at one time someone was
having a conversation with someone while
they were cutting my hand they cut it to
like way too short for stranger things
and so in the first season I wore hair
extensions oh man I never thought that
at a 12 year old the mullet model yeah
exactly what is Finn wolfhard's blood
type well I have absolutely no idea
um he'll drink anything yeah yeah truly
that's yeah I think they just want to
see if they can clone me someone wants
to clone me and that's how they're
trying to get it through Google what is
Finn wolfhard's style I like hip stuff
no no hipster stuff I don't know I like
vintagey stuff and like Japanese
Workwear and stuff like that how your
favorite big I'm tall final one final
one ready what is Guerra Del Toro
favorite color they got wild gas gyro
Del Toro jobs nice sold newspapers I
wasn't real estate I tried to be a car
salesman I didn't sell a single car I
was an ad sound guy a wardrobe assistant
a makeup effects stop-motion animator
etc etc there's no job in the world ever
that is not useful for you directing if
you're observing and you're attentive
now you know quiero Del Toro books The
Bleak houses are made of books there are
13 libraries organized by book and shelf
and author that I organized myself such
as my life when I'm not painting models
I'm organizing shelf the glamor never
and kids I've written on coverage in
four books it's more fun than in a way
because you you have no budget you can
do anything you want you say 10 000
vampires run down Times Square and
you're like a hundred thousand vampires
is really really fun
I think he doesn't know blood type yeah
I
bet that's a bad thing I should look at
my birth certificate
oh no I don't yeah so we're screwed if
we ever have a blood transfusion I'll
give you medicine okay man
[Music]